[Música]
sí
y
igual
mientras mis manos
todo lo que hacemos
por qué
ah
[Música]
era la rueda
el mismo
d
todos
estás viendo
al final
y ahora
es por eso que fue abandonada
qué estamos haciendo nosotros
que todos
[Música]
solo
si en ese tiempo
a ellos
pero de nada
sí
y me dice
y entonces al azúcar
tiene
en el corazón
no sé qué pasó con él
la duda
[Música]
rojo
d
cómo puede ser
i
si tenemos relaciones
a las pilas
y quizás
[Música]
es el momento
y entonces ahora vamos a tener
empezamos bien
bueno
la dura vida
[Música]
sabiamente
según el balance
en el mundo
nosotros somos
porque a ver de qué es esto
[Música]
que dejaba en esa posición
sí
a tres puntos
[Música]
una ciudad
estuve
y quiero
y nada más
aunque
e
entonces ejercicio
[Música]
una vez
como socialmente como la verdad
no podría hacer mucho más
una
qué va a pasar
y hacer y
nosotros
y
era una realidad
nuestros productos estos
[Música]
y
trabajar
así es cocinar
los días que terminaron en el casino
qué es
ahora sí
[Música]
sí
no no
nosotros en el pasado
[Música]
en distintas
sí
y
y ahora
bueno
[Música]
hola
vamos a casa
sí no
[Música]
si nos unimos
o
[Música]
esto ya viene a la cabeza más altas de
funciones
sin decir nada como esto
lo que pasa entonces
vamos a comprar aquí
porque nosotros
y
[Música]
no no
no
no sabemos por qué cuesta tanto decir
de esa forma para formar una salsa de
caramelo
nosotros
y tú
no
[Música]
dice que tenía la cabeza
ay
i
[Música]
la escuela
vamos a tomar
no solamente
es comida
no no no
vamos a ver qué pasa
sólo él
con formas
ahora
también y
empiece a utilizar
no sé
ah
[Música]
o
o no
este fin de semana
[Música]
el mal
igualdad
de ese sentimiento
así sea
es decir
se tiene
punto
mira
ciudad
precioso
hola
[Música]
ahora
no
y si no la hay
la dulce
[Aplausos]